Our scripture reading will be out of Ephesians 2, 1 through 10.
And you were dead in the trespasses and sins in which you once walked,
following the course of this world, following the prince of the power of the air,
the spirit that is now at work in the sons of disobedience,
among whom we all once lived in the passions of our flesh,
carrying out the desires of the body and the mind.
And we're by nature children of wrath like the rest of mankind.
But God, being rich in mercy because of the great love with which he has loved us,
even when we were dead in our trespasses, made us alive together with Christ.
By grace you have been saved and raised up with him
and seated us with him in the heavenly places in Christ Jesus,
so that in the coming ages he might show the immeasurable riches of his grace
and kindness towards us in Christ Jesus.
For by grace you have been saved through faith, and this is not of your own doing.
It is the gift of God, not a result of works so that no one may boast.
For we are his workmanship created in Christ Jesus for good works,
which God prepared beforehand that we should walk in them.
This is the word of the Lord.
So we're going to be going through Ephesians chapter 2.
This morning we saw the first part of it last week,
and we're going to be going through the next little bit here.
Just as we get started, I'll share a little story with you.
Back in 1773 an Anglican minister in England sat down to write his New Year's sermon,
and he was looking back at the year that had just passed
and looking forward to the year to come.
And so he decided to write a hymn to go along with his New Year's sermon.
He gave it the sensational, memorable title,
Faith's Review and Expectation.
So to go along with the sermon, look back in the past to see what God had done,
Faith's Review, and look forward in expectation of what God would do in the future.
So have you heard Faith's Review and Expectation before that old hymn?
I mean, you may have.
It's now one of the most popular songs that has ever been written.
The Library of Congress has over 3,000 recordings of it on file.
It's been recorded well over 6,000 times,
and it's been performed millions of times, even in space on the backpipes.
And it begins this way, Faith's Review and Expectation.
Amazing grace, how sweet the sound.
That saved a wretch like me.
I once was lost, but now I'm found.
Was blind, but now I see.
Amazing grace as it's now known was deeply personal to John Newton,
not just for his sermon.
He was a man who knew that he had received God's grace
and had been transformed by it.
If you're not familiar with this story,
I'd encourage you to go grab a biography,
because he was, for example, he had been involved in the slave trade
and having been transformed by God's grace.
He was then an ally in the abolitionist movement.
He was against slavery.
His life had been transformed by grace.
What is it about that song, Amazing Grace,
that resonates with so many people?
You hear it sung not just in churches,
but in kind of non-religious contexts as well.
What is so amazing about grace?
Well, our passage this morning shows us
and the whole message of Ephesians 2 verses 1-10
can really be summarized by a phrase that Paul repeats
in verse 5 and verse 8, and it is this,
By grace you have been saved.
So this morning we're going to simply look at
what it means to be saved by grace.
And we're going to consider that by looking at
three or four kind of key concepts here.
We're going to look at salvation,
we're going to look at being saved.
We're going to look at then grace,
and we're going to look at faith,
and we're going to look at good works.
We're just going to walk through those together.
So first of all, salvation.
By grace you have been saved.
Salvation is one of those words that gets kind of thrown
around in Christian circles,
and there can be a lot of confusion.
You might hear about how many people got saved
at a particular church meeting,
or somebody might ask you if you have been saved.
What does it really mean to be saved?
Well the word simply means to rescue.
Inherent in the word saved or salvation
is being in a place of danger or peril or harm.
In the Bible you see it used in a couple of different ways.
One is you see it being used in reference to people
who are in physical need or physical danger.
So Mark chapter 5, a diseased woman reaches out
and touches the hem of Jesus' garment,
and she's healed.
And she said that she did that in order to be saved.
And what she meant was that she was reaching out
in her need to be healed of her disease.
And the word she uses to describe that
is the same word here in Ephesians 2 for saved.
In Matthew chapter 14, you see Peter, the disciple,
walking on the water with Jesus.
It's a miracle.
Of course Peter then looks at the wind in the waves.
He begins to sink and as he's sinking he cries out,
Lord save me.
What is he saying there?
He's not saying, Lord take me to heaven when I drown.
He's not saying that.
He's saying I'm drowning please pull me out of this sea.
So that being said, yes,
refers to being saved from physical danger
but it also and most often so refers to our spiritual need.
And that is what Paul is referring to here.
So we need to see that spiritual danger is just as real
as any physical danger that we might face.
Speaking of danger and kind of darker things,
I mean this past month it's been kind of normal
to decorate your yard with tombstones
and other reminders of death and all the rest.
And I understand that but also there are times
when it has even kept people from seeing actual danger
that they were in.
So I read a story about a haunted house attraction in Nashville
where some teenagers were going around with some friends
and they were laughing having a great time
and then one of them grabbed a prop which was a knife
and they then proceeded to go for their friend with it
only to find out afterwards that it wasn't just a prop.
It was an actual real knife that had been used.
Thankfully their friend survived.
But when it comes to spiritual need and the danger we're in,
we're not just dealing with a kind of representation.
Paul's not sort of giving us a prop here to give us an idea.
He's talking about real danger that we are in.
And last Sunday Richard really helped us walking through
the opening verses of Ephesians chapter 2
showing us the terrifying reality of our spiritual condition
without Christ at the start of the chapter.
And I'm not going to revisit everything he said last week
but we are, if we're going to understand salvation
we need to see the desperate situation that we are in.
So Paul's talking about salvation because of what he said earlier.
So why do we need to be saved or rescued?
What is the specific danger?
We need to be saved because of, to remind us,
we need to be saved because of who we were.
So it says at the start, verse 1, and then he repeats it in verse 5,
you were dead in your trespasses and sins.
In chapter 2 and verse 3 he says,
you were by nature, children of wrath like the rest of mankind.
In other words, our fallenness goes right to the core of who we are.
We are sinners by nature and this is true of, it says,
all of mankind.
This is true ever since the fall of man in the garden.
You can go back to Genesis chapter 3 or read about that in Romans chapter 5.
We are all sinners by nature.
And this is described here as death.
It isn't merely pointing to the fact that we're just going to die one day physically.
It tells us that even while we were alive physically,
we were already dead spiritually when we came into this world.
You see, our sin separates us from God and if you are separated from God,
you are cut off from the very source of life.
So we need to be saved because of who we are by nature.
We also need to be saved because of what we did.
We who were by nature sinners then sinned.
In other words, our behavior showed our sin nature.
So you don't have to teach a person to sin anymore and you've got to teach a dog to bark.
It comes out naturally.
So our sin comes out how?
We saw it in that we live according to our own sinful desires that spoke about.
We live according to the pattern of this world.
We live according to the power of spiritual darkness.
So we were so entrenched in this way of life that we cannot break free from it any more
than someone who is dead can break free from coffin.
And that's the reality of our condition without Christ.
So what's that mean for us?
Some view Christianity as a way to maybe enrich their life
or to make a few improvements here and there.
They might think, well, I mean, generally speaking,
I'm a pretty good person and of course I need a little forgiveness here and there
and a help to improve my life.
And so Christianity comes in to kind of help you make some improvements.
But the problem we see here goes far deeper than that.
Paul doesn't like take us to a beauty shop to make a few improvements
or to give us a makeover.
He takes us to the morgue and he says,
this is how dire your natural spiritual condition is.
Fact is you can make all the kind of religious external improvements you want,
but then that cannot change the spiritual condition that you are in.
This radical problem requires a radical solution.
If you're dead, the only solution that we'll do is resurrection.
And the good news is that God raises the dead.
And this is the salvation he provides.
He gives us new life.
So how does he do it?
Let's move on to the second word then.
So we're saved.
So it tells us about the spiritual danger that we're in and God rescues us from that.
And he does it by grace.
So grace is a favorite word of the apostle Paul.
He uses it some 86 times in the New Testament.
So what does it mean?
Well, most commonly it's defined as unmerited favor.
And that's absolutely right.
In verse five, we see that God is rich in mercy.
So we might compare it to mercy.
So mercy is God not giving us what we do deserve,
withholding His wrath, and grace is God giving us freely what we do not deserve.
He freely gives us the gift of salvation.
It's his unmerited favor.
But like our sinful actions flow from our sinful nature,
so his gracious actions, his kindness towards us,
flows from his gracious nature.
This is speaking of who God is and what he does when it speaks of grace here.
So grace is about who God is.
So God is gracious by his very nature,
and he cannot be any more or any less gracious than he already is.
So 1 Peter chapter five and verse 10 refers to God as the God of all grace.
You see it pointing us to God himself in the text.
I mean, the whole thing hinges on those two words, but God.
So we were dead in our sin, but God steps in to save us by His grace.
So grace is, we might say, the disposition of God's heart
that inclines him to pour out his kindness upon us, freely giving us salvation.
But notice how gracious he is here.
You know, is he frugal with his grace?
Does he kind of carefully comb over his monitored budget
to see how much he can spare this month?
No, Paul speaks about his immeasurable grace,
the immeasurable riches of his grace.
So God is rich not only in the sense that he ultimately owns everything,
he's rich in terms of his gracious character
and his utter willingness to freely give again and again.
He gladly lavishes his grace upon us.
And no matter how much grace he shows, there's more where it came from.
And in fact, in fact, you see in chapter two and verse seven,
it will take all of eternity for him to put his grace on display
and his continual kindness towards us as his people.
So grace is about who God is by nature, but it's also about what he gives.
So his character is seen in his actions.
And salvation here is the specific gift of grace that Paul is emphasizing here.
So let's return to what kind of salvation we need.
If we're dead, we need new life.
So how does God graciously give us new life?
The answer is in Christ.
So a few weeks ago, in the kind of very first talk based on Ephesians chapter one
verses kind of one to two, we looked at our identity in Christ
and Paul is returning to that theme here really.
So over and over, Paul talks about us being in Christ,
about how our life is bound up in his, in other words.
So but here in this text, Paul speaks about it in a slightly different way.
Three times, notice in verses five and six,
he speaks about us being together with Christ.
You see it?
Verse five, he makes us alive together with Christ.
He raised us up with him.
He seats us with him in the heavenly places in Christ Jesus.
So here's what God does by his grace.
He unites us to Christ and he graciously causes us to participate
in what happens to him.
And we share with Christ in his death, in his resurrection,
in his ascension, and we are now seated together with him in heavenly places.
I don't know about you, but I enjoy watching a good helicopter rescue.
You know, there's one that tends to happen once a year or so.
I typed it in on YouTube this past week.
And there's so many that come up where somebody is say in a raging river
and then the rescue crew comes in with a helicopter
and it kind of repels down.
And when they get to them in the river, they harness them to themselves.
They kind of strap them in and then they get pulled right back up out of that raging river.
And they go right up to where the helicopter is and they're pulled in
and maybe they then head off to a hospital where they land there
and they're brought to safety.
Why do I share that?
I share that because you almost see like a similar movement in salvation here.
So God comes down, if you will, in a rescue mission in the person of Jesus.
Jesus descends into death.
He rises again and ascends to his Father in heaven.
You see that movement there?
And like this kind of river rescue, if you will, he unites us to himself.
He harnesses us to himself.
We are united to him.
And so where he goes, we go.
Right? So we died with him.
And God gives us new life with him.
And that life goes on forever with him.
That is how gracious God is.
But let me draw your attention to verse nine.
We're going to get into this a little bit more in a second.
But when it speaks about God's grace there, in verse eight about it being the gift of God,
it then talks about it not being a result of works so that no one may boast.
So if it is by grace, therefore, it means it is not of works.
If it was of works, we could boast in contributing to our salvation in some way.
So all the glory goes to God because it is entirely of his grace that we are saved.
So there's nothing.
No amount of religion, no amount of good works that can make us right with God.
And that's a very different message to literally every other religion in the world.
Religion says, do.
Grace says, it's done.
Religion is about what we do to get to God.
Grace is about what God did for us in Jesus when he came to save us.
And that's perhaps easy to recognize when you're talking about an obviously non-Christian religion,
but there are some slippery versions out there as well that would kind of take the name of Christian on,
but preach a message of works rather than grace.
So take Mormonism for example.
Now, don't miss hearing this.
We've got some very dear Mormon friends for example, the best neighbors you could have asked for.
But I do take issue with Mormonism and one of the reasons is this very issue.
So I'll give you a verse from the Book of Mormon.
Second Nephi, chapter 25 verse 23.
Notice how it almost echoes what Paul says here in Ephesians 2, 8, 9.
It says, for we know that it is by grace that we are saved after all that we can do.
Do you see the difference?
One says by grace you are saved, it is not of works.
The other says by grace you are saved after all that you can do.
The fact is here, it's clear, we cannot do anything to save ourselves.
You can't give yourself a new life any more than a dead man can give himself new life.
It isn't that we do our part, that we do the best we can and then God's grace makes up the rest.
The God who is immeasurably rich in grace isn't looking to kind of split the bill with us when it comes to salvation.
He's already paid for it and he gives it to us freely.
So salvation is not some reward that we achieve.
It is a gift that we receive.
So if you can't earn it, you might ask, well how can you know that you've received it?
Okay, so salvation is entirely of grace. How can I know that I've received that gift of salvation?
Ephesians 2 verse 8.
It repeats that phrase by grace you have been saved, it was in verse 5, but then it adds the two words, through faith.
So God's gift of salvation comes to us through faith.
So Romans chapter 4 verse 5, one of many verses that speaks of this, but I'll read it as well.
It says,
And to the one who does not work but believes in him who justifies the ungodly,
his faith is counted as righteousness. So we're saved through faith. So what is faith?
But simply it is trusting in Jesus to save you.
It's trusting in Christ.
We don't trust in our good works, our church attendance, our giving, our helping, our neighbor, whatever it is.
We don't trust in the sincerity of a decision we made years ago when we wrote the date in our Bible that we were told to,
and we look back and like we put our trust in our decision itself.
We put our trust in Christ himself, what he has done for us.
So it is believing, yes, faith is believing, but it's more than just acknowledging that something is true intellectually.
It is trusting in the grace of God to save you because of what Christ has done for you.
It is entrusting yourself to the one who died and rose again to bring us to God.
So have you put your faith in Jesus?
Back in the 19th century there was a Trapeze artist by the name of Blondin.
I'm sure that's not how you pronounce it.
He was a French guy and he actually did some work near where we used to live in England doing his Trapeze work.
Perhaps his most famous thing he ever did was go across Niagara Falls.
So he went across Niagara Falls and the crowd was all there cheering him on as he walked across and came back.
Also he then got this wheelbarrow.
He went across with a wheelbarrow and then he went to the crowd and he said,
Who believes that I can take someone across in this wheelbarrow?
Of course the crowd cheered.
Yeah, you can do it.
And he said, OK, who's going to get in the wheelbarrow?
And it was quiet.
You might say believed that he could do it, but were they willing to put their faith in him to actually trust in him?
Do you see the difference there?
And in the same way we can say, well, yeah, I believe that there was this man Jesus that he died for a sins, that he rose again.
That's all true.
But you know, the devil believes and he trembles.
He's not saved.
Faith is putting your trust personally in that one who died and rose again.
It's getting into the wheelbarrow.
It's entrusting yourself to him.
But notice what else it says about faith.
It is a gift of God.
So when he says you've been saved by grace through faith, he then says, and this is not your own doing.
It is the gift of God.
And the it spoken of here refers really to the whole movement of salvation that you see happening in this passage.
And that includes our faith in him.
All of it is by grace.
Both our salvation and the means by which we are saved.
So like we said earlier, it isn't that we do our part and then God does his.
So faith is the means by which we receive salvation.
Yes, but it isn't transactional.
It isn't like, okay, I bring my faith to the table and God brings his grace to the table.
Even the faith that receives salvation is a gift of grace.
And we don't just see that here in Ephesians chapter two.
You can see this in other places in scripture.
So you look at Philippians chapter one in verse 29 speaks of faith as a gift from God.
But I'm fascinated walking through the book of Acts seeing it play out in practice there in the early church.
Like as Luke writes about people coming to faith in Christ, it's interesting what he writes.
So take Acts chapter three and verse 16.
He speaks about people putting their faith in Jesus.
And in that same verse in the same breath, he talks about the faith that is through Jesus.
So faith in Jesus is also faith through Jesus.
Right?
So it's in him and it's through him.
The word faith isn't used in Acts chapter 16 verse 14.
But it talks about how as Paul preaches the gospel in Philippi, a lady called Lydia responds to the message of the gospel.
It's clear that she responds in faith.
But here's how it describes her response.
It says, the Lord opened Lydia's heart to pay attention to what was being said by Paul.
So why was she listening?
Why was she paying attention?
Because the Lord opened her heart so that she would hear what he was saying.
It talks about the Bible teacher Apollos in Acts chapter 18 verse 27.
And it describes his ministry in this way.
It talks about how he helped those who had believed through grace.
So he was helping these believers.
How did they believe through grace?
We might say, well, what does that matter?
Why are we making that kind of distinction here that both grace receives the gift and is in itself a gift?
Well, it matters for several reasons.
Let me just give you a couple.
One that I take great comfort in personally, it's not in the text.
So this is just kind of me over here sharing something.
I find it a great comfort that I can pray for someone's salvation, someone who does not know the Lord.
And I can pray with confidence that God is able to save them.
I can pray that they would hear the message of the gospel, that they would believe in Christ.
And know that God is able to give them the faith that he calls them to.
So we can all do that.
So let's pray that people would be saved that God would give that to them.
But the reason that is given here in the text, once again, is what we might, or what Paul calls, boasting.
So when it comes to our salvation, we have nothing to boast in.
Not even our faith in him.
We boast in Jesus and in him alone.
We boast in grace.
We give God all the glory.
All right.
But to say that salvation is through faith alone, finally, is not to say that good works do not matter.
They do.
Now salvation, so let's think about good works together.
Salvation is not a result of our good works, but it does result in good works.
So good works is not the root of our salvation, we might say, but it is the fruit of our salvation.
Last week on Halloween Day, I had somebody come up to me and wished me a happy Reformation Day.
And what they were referring to is back on October 31st, 1517, the German reformer Martin Luther nailed his 95 thesis to a church door in Wittenberg.
And that's kind of marked as the kind of start of the Protestant Reformation.
And there were some major truths of Scripture that were there all along that were kind of recovered and preached once again.
One of them being the salvation is by grace alone through faith alone.
But we also see that the reformers did not downplay the importance of our works, that they clearly preached salvation through faith alone.
So let me give you a quote from John Calvin, another reformer.
He says, it is therefore faith alone which justifies and yet the faith which justifies is not alone.
So that's kind of been paraphrased a number of times as the faith that is faith alone that saves but faith that saves is never alone.
So what is meant by that there?
So if we've been saved through faith, then that will be seen in the good works that follow.
And you see that in verse 10, what does it say?
It says, for we are his workmanship created in Christ Jesus.
Why does he create us in Christ Jesus?
It's revisiting what we've already seen that new life in Christ for good works which God prepared beforehand that we should walk in them.
Now having just said everything I said, you could argue that we are saved by good works.
It's just not our good works.
It's his good works.
We are his workmanship.
So the God who formed Adam from the dust of the ground and breathed life in him created us anew in Christ Jesus.
Second Corinthians chapter 5 verse 17 says, therefore if anyone is in Christ, he has a new creation.
If he has passed away behold the new has come.
Alright so he's created us in Christ Jesus.
Why did he create us?
Well when God created man and placed him in the garden, what came next?
Genesis chapter 2 and verse 15, he gave him work to do in the garden.
And that work was before the fall.
In other words it was good.
You see that flow happening there in the order of creation.
The same thing is happening in new creation here.
So we weren't made a new creation in Christ so that we could kind of sit around and say, well isn't that great?
We were saved, made new in Christ that we might work.
You see the life that we have in Christ is seen in the life that we then live for Christ.
And those good works are laid out for us by the way specifically in detail in chapter 4, 5 and 6 of the text.
So that's the kind of flow of Ephesians.
Chapters 1 to 3 we see this is who we are in Christ.
Chapters 4 to 6 this is what it means looks like to walk in him.
And so there are good works that are general for every believer.
But then there are also gifts that he's given to us individually.
And specific opportunities for good works.
And he's prepared those for us to walk in as well.
So just see here the chapters come full circle from verse 1 to verse 10.
Before we were following after our sinful desires, following after the pattern of the world and the devil.
And now we are following after Christ.
We're living for him because of what he has done for us because we have been given this new life in him.
The new life is seen in that growth that takes place, growth in his likeness.
That doesn't mean we'll be perfect far from it but we can say with John Newton.
I am not the man I ought to be.
I am not the man I wish to be.
I'm not the man I hope to be.
But by the grace of God I am not the man I used to be by his grace I am who I am.
A few years ago there's a guy who was cataloging music for a museum.
And while he was kind of cataloging it, he noticed a file he hadn't seen before.
It kind of dropped out.
It was a piece of music.
And on that piece of music had the name of the legendary composer.
I'm a butcher, pronunciation Chopin.
C-H-O-P-I-N.
And as he pulled it out and he said, could that really be his?
You could look it up on the BBC.
He pulled it out and he walked over to a piano and sure enough he played it.
And it was this beautiful piece of music.
And that music had been sat there for years.
And the first time it was played was fairly recently.
I think it was like 2019.
It was amazing.
The good works that God has prepared for us were prepared beforehand.
And now the call is for us to take them and to play them out, to walk in them.
In fact, the word that he uses for workmanship here is poema.
It's where we get our English word poem from.
We could say that we are his poetry.
But that word is used to refer to any kind of like work of art.
So it isn't a stretch to say that God has created this piece of music
and it is sounding out through our lives.
And his workmanship is coming through as we who have been saved by his grace.
Also live by his grace for his glory.
And what does that music sound like?
You might say it sounds like amazing grace.
It looks like the grace of our Lord Jesus Christ.
So let's pray now.
Lord, we thank you so much for the amazing grace that you have shown us in Jesus.
And so Lord, I pray that even if there's anyone here who has not received the gift of your salvation through Jesus.
Lord, I pray that you would help them, enable them to come to you, to put their trust in Jesus.
Receive the gift of salvation by faith.
Lord, I pray that you would help us to live out of that grace.
That we would not fall back into old patterns of depending on our own good works or following after our own desires.
Lord, I pray that you would fill us with so much gratitude for what you have done for us in Jesus that we would long to live for him.
Lord, we thank you that the life that is lived for him is the life that is lived by him.
So I pray that you would help us by your grace to live as your workmanship in the world.
So Lord, we pray that our lives would be lived by your grace and for your glory.
In Jesus' name. Amen.